[Musique]
de plus en plus de nouvelles
contaminations 9605 nouveaux cas de
contaminations ont été recensés ces 24
dernières heures 6667 personnes sont
hospitalisées avant le président va
parler on écouter tous là maintenant on
sait qu'il va dire une chose mais il
peut dire le contraire le lendemain
c'est ça le dérange pas il a tout dit on
n'a pas besoin de Max il faut mettre des
masques pas de test s'il déteste la
campagne de rappel vaccinale elle a
commencé vous le savez depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines elle a démarré très
timidement aujourd'hui il y a une
progression encourageante mais qui est
insuffisante avec moi d'une personne
éligible sur deux qui a reçu sa
troisième dose et son rappel est-ce que
la troisième dose pourrait être liée au
Pass sanitaire ou vice-versa le Pass
sanitaire la troisième dose
à ce stade ce n'est pas sur la table mon
discours mondiagnostic mais solutions
sont entendues par un nombre croissant
de Français voilà c'est tout donc vous
n'allez pas laisser tomber ces gens-là
ces gens là donc c'est une histoire de
date
vous voulez en tout cas je ne pense pas
je vous pose vous savez c'est simple je
ne vais pas laisser tomber ces gens-là
je me suis beaucoup moins obsédé pour
que vous c'est pas moi qui ai fait
encore très récemment une couverture à
l'effigie de ce monsieur c'est pas moi
qui livre justement
j'ai les bonnes solutions et que je sais
comment faire pour les mettre en oeuvre
c'est la faute ce n'est pas la faute des
politiques mais il s'agit pas de fautes
pas de responsabilité
je vais pas recevoir de la part des des
pyromanes permanents que vous êtes en
véhicule en vous-même ses propres idées
suis quand même potentiellement au
second tour
qui le cru qui le cru il y a seulement
un mois et demi au soyez honnêtes
personne même pas moi si là nous perdons
et que nous ne sommes pas au deuxième
tour nous disparaîtrons en tant que
grande formation politique capable de
remporter cette élection majeure qui est
la présidentielle
Eric Zemmour c'est le vote assurance
d'Emmanuel Macron que le seul qui se
réjouit de la montée d'Éric Zemmour dans
les sondages c'est Emmanuel Macron parce
que le discours de Derrick Zemmour est
tellement caricatural est tellement
brutal qui l'offre la réélection
d'Emmanuel Macron sur un plateau quand
je vois tous ces gens de droite de
gauche venir se recueillir sur la tombe
du général de Gaulle j'ai l'impression
de l'hommage du vice à la vertu c'est à
dire que ces gens là sont tous tous je
dis bien tous des traîtres au général de
Gaulle on ne sait plus attirer la
machine à intégrer une fonction plus
donc je défends l'intégration ou rien
donc pour moi la question du travail
fondamentale vous savez que c'est au
cœur de mon projet mais c'est la France
qui est en cause et qui ne sait plus
moi pour moi c'est que on ne s'en occupe
pas on a laissé faire une bousculade
lors du festival de musique astroword
qui est à l'origine de CDC vers 21h
heure locale la foule a commencé à se
presser devant la scène d'un des
concerts de ce festival provoquant un
mouvement de panique 8 personnes sont
décédées 360 mètres de long 64 dollars
7000 passagers 2000 membres d'équipage
une ville flottante de 19 étages quitte
Saint-Nazaire des milliers de personnes
se sont massées sur les bords de
l'estuaire de la Loire pour voir le plus
gros paquebot du monde prendre la mer
retour sur terre de Thomas Pesquet et
trois de ses collègues astronautes et
reporté de 24 heures en raison de vent
violents à proximité de la zone
d'amerrissage cette image hier après une
mission de 6 mois le commandant Pesquet
transmettait les clés à son homologue
russe la capsule va se détacher de l'ISS
demain soir ensuite 408 km et 18h de
trajet sans toilette elles sont
condamnées à cause d'une fuite
rassurez-vous les combinaisons des
astronautes intègrent des sous-vêtements
absorbants
je suis désolé